Thor's new look in Avengers: Endgame has been
a hot topic amongst Marvel fans since the
moment the film dropped in theaters.
People have been bickering back and forth
over whether the god of thunder gaining a
noticeable amount of weight, letting his hair
grow long and his beard get scraggly, and
settling into a routine of beer, chips, and
video games was a cheap attempt at laughs
or an accurate depiction of the effects trauma
and grief can have on a person.
Amongst all this chatter, one person who has
remained pretty quiet about "fat Thor" in
Endgame is Thor himself, famously fit actor
Chris Hemsworth.
Thanks to Endgame directors Joe and Anthony
Russo, we know how Hemsworth reacted to the
news that his hammer-swinging hero character
would sport a different physique in the film.
Speaking in a recent interview with Sirius
XM, the Russos shared that Hemsworth was totally
on board for chubby Thor and was ready to
take the character in a new direction.
As Joe Russo put it,
"Hemsworth is up for anything.
He likes to take risks."
"That's a nice way of putting it."
Anthony chimed in from there, explaining that
he and Joe gave Hemsworth a call to discuss
where Thor's personal journey would go in
Endgame and how his character arc would wrap
up.
The initial conversation took place quite
a while before Endgame and its predecessor
Infinity War, which were shot back-to-back,
began filming, meaning the Russos and Hemsworth
knew well in advance what Thor would look,
feel, and act like in the epic ensemble movie.
Anthony Russo said,
"Before the script was ready, when we called
him to pitch the character arc, he was either
still finishing or had just finished Ragnarok.
But he was so energized by the work he had
done with Taika [Waititi] in that movie in
terms of coming up with a comedic and irreverent
Thor."
Anthony's brother Joe finished the thought,
saying,
"And we were like, 'Wait until you hear what
we've got for you.'"
Hemsworth couldn't open up much about what
happened with Thor in Endgame or offer explicit
details about the hero's transformation until
the movie premiered in theaters in late April,
but he did offer a tiny tease to USA Today
ahead of the pic's debut.
The Aussie actor told the outlet that he and
the Russos had multiple, in-depth talks regarding
Thor's change from the god of thunder with
lightning coursing through his veins to a
self-conscious guy that his fellow Avengers
tease has Cheez Whiz flowing through him instead.
Of course, Hemsworth had to keep mum about
the specifics at that time, though he did
explain that he, quote, "wanted to do something
different" and push Thor to his limits in
Endgame.
He told USA Today,
"[The Russos] were on board and we sat for
many hours and days and discussed kind of
how far we could push it and what we could
do different."
"Fat Thor" certainly is different to any other
iteration of the hero fans have seen in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe before.
It was a bold move on the part of Hemsworth
and the Russo brothers, and definitely caused
a rift in the Marvel fandom, but it's evident
that there was no ill intent behind the decision.
Rather, it sounds like the Endgame team wanted
to depict Thor in a brand-new light while
making a point about how everyone handles
feelings of grief and guilt in their own ways
and how there isn't just one right way to
be a hero.
One of the most prominent takeaways from "fat
Thor" in the film is that he never underwent
a fat-to-fit transformation in order to boost
his confidence or to prove to himself and
others that he is worthy of being a superhero.
Instead, Thor was able to summon his hammer
Mjolnir and fight the brutal battle against
Thanos at the end of Endgame, while keeping
on the extra pounds he gained over the five
years post-Snap.
He may not look the way he used to, but he's
just as powerful, and that's an important
message to send to audiences.
Like Avengers: Endgame screenwriter Christopher
Markus once explained,
"We leave him in that state at the end of
the movie.
Even though he's emotionally resolved.
We fix his problem, and it's not his weight…
And I think he is the ideal Thor at the end
of the movie, and he's carrying some weight."
And as Anthony Russo stated in a recent interview,
"We find 'fat Thor' as inspiring as any version
of Thor because he's so relatable.
It's a very human version of the character."
Thor appears positioned to make a return in
the MCU with Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
3, given where he wound up at the end of Endgame.
The Russos did note in their Sirius XM interview
that it's ultimately up to director James
Gunn whether Thor plays a part in the upcoming
film, but if he does, it seems his big belly
and bushy beard might be coming back, too.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.